[Music]
what up guys goes in for anime uproar
and today we're going to talk about
every Titan that's right so every Titan
abnormals in every specific Titan
shifter we're going to look at them
explain their strengths their weaknesses
and all-around
important information about them so
obviously for this explanation I will
need to go into manga so there will be
some manga spoilers be prepared for that
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
for more attack on Titan and anime
related videos anyways what's out
further ado and if you're still with me
let's get to it so we're going to be
looking at four types of titans there
are pure Titans abnormals wall tightens
and tightens if ters for pure Titans
they range between three to fifteen
meters in height these Titans composed
the vast majority of all Titans some
walk on two feet while others walk on
four they're pretty mindless in nature
don't know what they're doing they would
always head towards the first human they
see and without planning or reasoning
which makes them actually easy to
deceive or learn to trap in the past
they were used by humans with the power
of the Titan as chief killing machines
against the other nations of the world
next is abnormal so that pretty much
means any Titan that acts abnormally or
has intelligence unlike most Titans
which just mindlessly attack and devour
the first human they see abnormals often
ignore nearby humans and actually charge
to more important locations where they
can do more damage the wall Titan look
like the colossal Titan in appearance
and can be found inside the walls
although they appeared to be alive
they're weak and immobile because of the
lack of sunlight they receive the
century ago these Titans were guided by
the first Kings founding titan and his
power of the Titans which all founding
Titans have and that pretty much allows
them to control all pure Titans and he
used that power to create the three
walls through the
hardening of these tightening skin
lastly and most importantly we have
Titan shifters humans who are capable of
transforming into Titan who have unique
traits and skills that can be honed and
improved upon
they are usually stronger and/or faster
than pure titans and retain their
intelligence during the controlled
transformation
they often resemble their shifter in
appearance amir fritz was the first
individual to receive the power of the
Titans she supposedly made a deal with
the devil of the earth so it will be
interesting as we read on to see who or
what God's devil turns out to be she
also supposedly used her powers as the
founding Titan who made great
advancements for her subjects such as
building bridges between mountains and
cultivating barren lands after 13 years
she died and that's also why every type
of shifter has the curse of a mirror it
can only live 13 years before passing
the power rock and Aamir's powers were
split after she died between nine Titans
the first of all Titan shifters and
specifically her power of the founding
Titan that allowed her to control all
Titans and erase memories of the LDN
people would be passed down through the
fritz family later renamed the Reese
family over the next two millenium these
nine Titans include the Beast Titan the
armored Titan
the colossal Titan the female Titan Jaws
Cartman the attack Titan as well as the
founding Titan now we're going to jump
into these Titans their powers their
owners as well as any other interesting
information about them the armored Titan
is a 15 meter class Titan it's possessed
by Raynor and special ability includes
very thick hardened plates of skin all
over the body that act as armor only
visible weaknesses are small areas on
the backs of its joint where there is no
armor not particularly fast this form is
strong and agile and capable of
destroying the fortified wall after a
sufficient running start can also
sacrifice some armor for speed as we've
seen
the curse of Amir remember that means it
can only live 13 years every time shut
certainly live 13 years after they
received the power according to that
Rayner only has two years left to live
in the manga the Colossus Titan or
colossal Titan is a 60 meter class which
is actually the second biggest Titan rod
Reese and his Titan form actually goes
up to 120 meters twice the height of the
colossal Titan however this Titan can't
even stand how big the colossal Titan
was actually possessed by virtual first
and then later by Armin it has slow
movements because of its height it is
strong enough to break down the walls
with a kick
special ability includes superheat which
allows us body to produce incredibly hot
steam as a defense
Bertolt can also release an explosive
amount of energy drink it typing
transformation which can completely
level buildings in a short radius it can
kill surrounding people and it generates
a mushroom cloud of speed as well it's
interesting to point out that this is
one of the few type transformations
which don't resemble the Titan user so
we can assume even if we haven't seen it
yet that Armond transformation as the
colossal Titan will also now resemble
Armin the female Titan is the 14 meter
class Titan and is possessed by Annie it
resembles Annie and is one of the few
Titans that has a distinctly feminine
body and short blond hair she has
immense strength and speed as well as
refined martial arts techniques she has
enough stamina to keep up with horses
over long distance and the intelligence
to predict and defend against vertical
maneuvering equipment special abilities
include the ability to harden its body
parts by generating a crystalline
substance across chosen areas of its
body this allows her to protect her nape
and fight simultaneously what's very
interesting is that she can also use
selective regeneration and focus her
regenerator power on one body part like
her eye and drastically increase the
time it takes to regenerate that body
part the female Titan also has the
ability to call other Titans to it and
drive them into a feed
frenzy the attack Titan is a 50-meter
class Titan it is currently possessed by
Eren Jaeger and was previously possessed
by Aaron Kruger who Aaron is named after
and Grisha Hagar Aaron's father who he
had to eat before obtaining the power it
has elongated years fleshly straws and
muscular body it also has great physical
strength martial arts techniques and
incredible endurance prolonged and
repeated use of his Titan form has
allowed Aaron to gradually increase his
control over it thanks to his father
Aaron also has the abilities of the
founding Titan within him which allows
him to take control of other Titans
however this only activates when he is
in contact with royal blood because only
one with royal blood can use the power
he comes into contact with royal blood
when he makes contact with Dina Jaeger
grisha's first wife in this blind state
of rage Aaron subconsciously commands
other Titans to relentlessly attack his
chosen targets after receiving the
armored Titan serum the attack tank also
hardened which allows him to seal the
hole in wall Maria the curse of a mere
means that Aaron only has four years
left to live next up the mysterious
beast Titan who stands at 17 meters tall
so the possessor is Zek who was actually
Aaron's half-brother Zach can actually
speak in Titan form he has a very unique
ape-like appearance his arms are long
gated and he has distinctly long fingers
he possesses massive strength and
accuracy which was seen when the Beast
Titan was able to accurately hit members
of the survey corpse with chunks of the
wall from very far away although the
founding Titan is usually the strongest
Titan currently the beast Titan is the
strongest while the founding Titan power
lays dormant in Aaron the beast Titan
under Zechs command also possesses the
special ability to guide and direct
mindless Titans and if the targets come
into contact with a spinal fluid the
Beast Titan can create new Titans from
common LD ins Titans under his control
can even function by moonlight however
his power is not as effective and
reliable as the founding Titans
commanding power one of the reasons
might be able to do this is because he
is related to Dina because he's her son
and Dina had royal blood which means eck
has royal blood as well because of the
curse of a mirror that caused one year
or less to live in the manga Jaws is a 5
meter class agile chimpanzee like Titan
it's possessed by a mere first and then
Galliard who is an alien warrior for the
male government just like Rainer it is
characterized by a mouth with all
pointed teeth special ability includes
an extremely powerful jaw it has
distinctly long arms and sharp claws its
size and shape allows for great speed
and agility Ameer was the only shifter
who actually roamed as a Titan for 60
years before she ate Marcel who was a
childhood friend of Rainer and been sold
and regained her humanity Cartman is
four metres tall and is currently
possessed by Peck I'm probably
butchering the name but we all know how
it's pronounced until it comes out into
anime unlike the other Titans this Titan
walks solely on four limbs as its name
implies her torso is long and flat
allowing for materials to be easily
packed onto the back P AK can use her
Titan form for very long periods of time
like two months but when she turns back
in her human form she has trouble
adjusting to walking on two legs and
needs a crutch she is the only female
Titan shifter whose Titans Thor attains
a male appearance last but not least we
have what should be the most powerful
Titan power the founding Titan it has an
ability that is capable of allowing the
user to control the actions of titans it
also allows the controller to modify the
memories of LDN and inherit the memories
of all individuals who previously
possess the ability while the last true
founding Titan was free to Reese the
power currently remains mostly dormant
within Eren and there you have it guys
every Titan type and Titan power
explained obviously I only touched the
surface here but if you guys want more
in-depth attack on Titan videos about
these specific Titans or anything else
give the video a like and let me know in
the comment section below I really hope
you enjoyed the video
and learn something new if you want more
of these videos be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell
thanks so much for watching and until
next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]